fue la primera visita de un presidente
de eeuu a cuba en 88 años el culmen de
un proceso que comenzó en diciembre de
2014 con el anuncio de un
restablecimiento de relaciones y la
apertura de una embajada de la unión
americana en la habana julio álvarez
propietario de un local de autos
clásicos recuerda esa época con
nostalgia yo espero que la amonestación
de bailén tomó en cuenta todo lo que
pasó que tenga mucha historia lo que
hicimos nosotros el crecimiento del
sector privado en cuba hoy el turismo
está lejos de la bonanza de esa época
este sector clave cayó un 75 el año
pasado de la mano de la pandemia y el
bloqueo a la llegada de cruceros parte
de las sanciones impuestas por la
administración de dawn trump que también
selló el regreso de la nación a la lista
de países patrocinadores del terrorismo
[Música]
no hay nuevas sanciones pero tampoco
está claro que vuelvan a vivirse tiempos
como los de obama las últimas elecciones
demostraron el poderío de la comunidad
cubana en florida dando votos cruciales
para la victoria de trump en el estado
civil sin ser un giro sobre la política
con cuba no está actualmente entre las
principales prioridades del presidente
wyden pero estamos comprometidos a hacer
de los derechos humanos un pilar de
nuestra política y estamos comprometidos
a revisar decisiones políticas hechas
por la administración anterior de
expansión mientras tanto la isla pone en
parte sus esperanzas de recuperación en
las vacunas contra el kobe de 19 este
viernes las autoridades científicas
anunciaron que una segunda candidata
entrará en la última fase de ensayos
clínicos sería el primer fármaco de este
tipo desarrollado en latinoamérica y se
muestra como una potencial fuente de
divisas y un atractivo adicional para
los turistas a los que cuba ofreció
vacunar